Hey Felix.
Yes Pewdie?
How come we never kiss on camera?
Because kissing is for faggots.
Come on, come on! Just give me a lil' smooch.
I need it for the thumbnail.
No! Get off!
You're gay!
But there's nothing wrong with two people kissing!
Oh, really?
Just watch this!
*intense music*
(Beware, some will be disgusted in the next scene!)
OOH!
KISSING VIDEOS!
It all started with Ti-ti-la play-va!
VIRAL VIDEO!
Hundred million views!
I don't think I have a hundred video meoademavideo...
"We asked 20 strangers to kiss for the first time..."
Girl: "Can you turn off the lights?"
Another Girl: "Huehuehuehue"
Girl: "Come on!"
Shy man: *stick out the hand* "Justin"
Curly girl: *stick out the hands too* "Huehuehue"
Wat am I watching?
a fuckin' dove commercial ?!
*inaudible music*
Dis feel stupid!
UGH!
This is WORTHLESS!
This is UGLY!*
(a lil' bit awkward, huh?)
This feels GAY!
woa! a..a..na..I..I
Ha! That just...
That's just ah... what other people told me!
*some comedy music kicks in* *with some zoom-in effect of course*
This god forbidden video launch a bunch of copies
*majestic slaps* there's one where people slap each other
*girly gesture* aw aw aw aw my gawd!
*earrapesound*
*poods notices ad* There's kiss me now, meet me later!
UGH
and then there's just the butt-scraping the bottom
ya know
There's just the ones that, just would..
They'll take three hundred thousand views gladly and put it in their pocket
BEST FRIENDS KISS FOR THE FIRST TIME!
(two half-men standing looking awkward)
Girl in the background : "are you ready ?"
Half-men in jacket: "This is weird..."
*kissing passionately*
OOOOOOOOOOOOH!
*some screaming shit*
OOOOOOOOOH !
UGH!
WHY ??
GAWD !
Why you do that ??
that's not how you do it
ogh
What we got here ?
Girl : "I'm hoping that he is a really great kisser, for sure"
Wait so this is love at first sight
So this people have never met before
They're gonna kiss each other
This should be great
Girl : "I love the first kiss, and maybe this will be the magic that i'm looking for.."
Men : "I think my strategy is just go for the kiss, maybe I'll be able to like slip-tounge...."
[That sounds like a gangsta name]
Maybe i'll be able to slip-tounge..
*silence poods*
Damn
This guy is a player *insert stupid comment saying he's a better player than poods*
Oh, damn..
They made eye contact
Aha, so cute..
Men : "Hello, how's it going ?"
Girl : "Good, how are you ?"
Men : "I'm good"
Men : "What's your name ?" *vomits out cringe*
Girl : "Emily.."
Men : "I'm Josh"
Emily : "Hi.."
Oh
I feel a lil' bit of chemistry goin'
Josh : "Heh.."
Josh : "Umm..Can I kiss you ?"
Emily : "Sure"
*burst of laughter*
Ahh..
No..
It hurt, it hurt so much..
Dat fucking face afterwards
Like..
FUCK YEAAAA
And he just leaves
HE JUST LEAVES !
HE JUST LEAAVEEES !!
WAT A PLAYA !!
Wasn't a whole lot of slipping-tounge action goin' there. Maybe the camera didn't really catch it *giggle*
Hot Gal : "Do you mind if I give you a kiss ??"
I mean, she's hot compare to him; Men : "Yeah".. Girl : "You mind ?"
Men : "No.. no.."
*bitchy laughter*
Men : "I don't mind.."
(look at dat fucking face)
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOGH !!!!
*music start playing*
"let me be your hero...."
*enrique iglesias' song play*
(that face tho)
*disgusted poods*
So this is a couple thats virg..the bro virgin..
Men : "I'm 31, and i have never kiss a girl on the lips"
Men : "We're saving our first kiss for our wedding"
Okay, so, we're gonna see them kiss
Here we go
*surprised and disgusted crowd shouting and screaming randomly*
*facepalm*
OOOOOOOOOGGGGGGGHHHHHHHHHHHHHH !!!!
It look like two aliens
It looks like they try to suck something out of each other's mouth
It looks like he's trying to choke her
It looks like she wants to die
It looks like they're eating each other
It looks like everything but kissing pretty much
I also kiss my girlfriend on camera once..
Very beautiful
Nothing like that cringy bullshit
Pewds : "I can't.."
Bradzia : "What are you ? Fucking gay ? Come on.." *high-pitched sound bullshit*
Bradzia : "Keep your eyes open, look at me when you kiss me.."
Let it be know, that..
Let it be know that, Brad, I mean Marzia..
He pulled out, alright
I commited
I ain't no fucking...
Gay pussy
Not that there's anything wrong with that !
There's so much fucking more material
*kiss intensively and awkwardly at the same time*
*giggle awkwardly*
I just wanna die
I just, wanna die
This is worse than handshake, just stop kissing !
Just stahp !
Girl : "He is going to some of his ex-girlfriends.."
"and kissing the mother's of these girls" *momma nervous laughter*
"to say in thirty years time, who he would be attracted to the most.."
Girl : "John would like me to ask you whether he could uhm.."
"make out with you"
Momma : "Oh that's a beautiful to a kiss"
How the fuck did I make fucking a fucking sense jesus fucking christ !
Okay, yeah..
Oh my god, it's so creepy
Ooh
OAAAAAGGGGHH
Girl : "No, stop"
Oooohhh
Girl : "No, no..really"
Girl : "No, really"
*momma's happy laughter after kissing*
*shocked*
It's this real ???
That's real ??!!
She just had to step in and be like..
No sorry, this guy is just too fucking much
THAT'S DISGUSTING !
Ooooooh
She loved it
Look at they're holding hand
I can't imagi..
Can you imagine your mom kissing another creepy ass fucking man ?
Especially australian ?
UUUGH
Sorry australian, but jesus christ
Men : "Okay, just a smaller kiss"
*making out noises*
OOOOOOGGGGHHHHHHH
Why does he go with his mouth open ?
*intense music*
JEEEEZZZUUUUZZZ CHRIST !
*dutch gibberish*
This is dutch...you fucking dutch ass weirdos
*more dutch gibberish*
Oh my god, look at how fucking excited he is to kiss that girl
Oh my gawd
Oh my god, he's running !
He's runnin' !
What is he gonna do ?
Oh he's up on the stage !
He's goin...
OOH!
HOOOH !
HOOOOOH!
WOOOooOOooOOOoo
HO HOOO !
Ahahahahahahahahahaha
*inhale*
Look at him !
Oh my gawd ! That look like it hurts !
*intense building up music*
*here comes the creepy face*
*wait for it*
*wait*
What is this Jaws kiss edition?
BOOOOM!
Kissing prank, pregnant edition
OOOKKHHHH
Noo
(this is sick)
This is..
..fuckin'..
..weird
Can you imagine feeling the belly while you do it ?
Oh god no....
NOOOOOOO!!!
It's this..
It's just..
I will give your stomach one kiss
Well that's about it
Okay
I think..
This's just a bad idea..
This's a bad idea
This is not good
Okay felix
I'll give you a, kiss..
Just for the views
*slowly going closer (✪㉨✪) *
*just a lil more (・∀・ ) *
*this is it (づ｡◕‿‿◕｡)づ*
WHY PEWDS D;
What are you ? Fucking gay ?
*Obvious attempt to not get disliked is obvious*
(It's 10:00! AD REVENUE!!)